hey it's the CNN welcome to part 1 of
CES 2020 there's so much stuff to see so
we better get started now this is sharps
90 inch to see-through display obviously
it is transparent but hold on a second I
can't actually see you because it's a
one-way mirror so when you guys come
around to this side to see what I'm
seeing you're not able to see out I'm
waving see oh right
behind me is the BMW I interaction ease
and what this is is a contact of what it
would be like in the future when there's
no steering wheels what this is is our
vision of the future of autonomous
mobility looking far out understanding
when autonomous mobility is more
commonplace how do you actually interact
and understand and enjoy that
environment I am relaxing now no way if
you tap again I will put the seat up
right what if I want to stay here
forever
by out of all of this technology one of
the things that has impressed me so much
is the technology over here this is what
I would like to call dorito technology I
don't think this joke was as good as I
thought it was so I'll just carry on
this is the brand-new instead 361 are
you guys know that I'm such a huge fan
of into 360 but what's great about this
is its modulus you can swap out
different pieces of it to make it a
different type of camera we have a 360
they have a one inch sensor and they
partnered with like up this is the like
a mod and this is so great because it is
a one since there's obviously you're
gonna get some really great low-light
having this inside of this little camera
this is the aerial audition there's two
different camera lenses there's 203 one
on the top and one on the bottom and
this ring connects to the brains of the
camera so this is our little LCD screen
and that in post everything gets
stitched together and it'll remove the
drone including the propellers it takes
a lot of skill to be an F BB drone pilot
with this you can kind of fake being an
F BB drone pilot because it is capturing
everything so you can recapture and
reframe and shoot as if you were
actually shooting a TV show this is
gonna upset a lot of fpv pilots but
don't worry your talent has not gone
unnoticed and you guys are so incredibly
talented the drone flag in such a
nutrient this is the 3d addition he'll
be able to shoot stereoscopic video 180
you guys know that I've done a couple
180 videos the future of this is
basically the possibilities are endless
because they can keep coming out with
different pieces of this and you can
make whatever type of camera that you
want this one is mine - don't let anyone
take it
these are great so one is did you win
unboxing that I didn't bring a knife
into CES so I was afraid I'd have to go
through a metal detector but guess what
we bought a knife anyway look at this
little guy
this is gonna be perfect on top of the
instant 36 eh this is a nice little rig
look at this they even have little
filters let's go vlogs we've got the low
setting medium high high it is really
bright oh my gosh it's a yoga synchro
visualizer you get to send us your
center of gravity
[Music]
in the visual representation of the
changes and your arms down
am I in trouble
[Music]
should I go to the doctor ash I go to
hospital immediately
I'm not sure if I'm okay I asked if I
was okay but it was too loud in there so
I don't know I mean should I go to the
hospital if what does this even mean I
don't know I feel fine
this is my first time riding a
motorcycle and it's electric
60 seconds
[Music]
I'm so scared I know it's not gonna go
anywhere
[Music]
[Applause]
so now all I need to the licensor litter
livewire I feel like we just transported
into another dimension TV rollup but you
can also have it installed in the
ceiling
[Music]
have the largest OLED 8k display here in
their booth it is 88 inches and the
screen is massive
this arm reminds me anytime I'm in the
bank and I'm sitting talking to like the
bank person and they're talking about
Bank things and they're like I have some
important information to show you
they spin it around show you the
information the spunk its vertical too
but see us know that I've been a huge
fan of the wallpaper TV was one of the
biggest complaints that well most people
has soundbar was a little bit big he
just kind of didn't really know where to
put it but this the TV is slightly
thicker than the wallpaper TV for the
sound Bart is so incredibly thin that
this makes so much more sense this is
the new design of the sound bar for the
OLED wallpaper TV you guys have seen me
unbox this before I love the
introduction of this new design as it is
so much more slim and compact the razor
kishi it'll turn your phone into
basically looks like a Nintendo switch
this won so many awards here at CES and
it's both iOS and Android compatible has
passed through powers will also charge
your phone
so this is razors concept 5g mesh router
it also has a built-in batteries so if
you do want to take it on the go
definitely possible what are the trends
recently is modular everything you guys
saw begins to 360 are well this is a
modular pc this is their tomahawk gaming
fest by kevin just told me that you can
build this thing within 30 seconds we're
hopping in raisers simulator here they
say this is one of the most realistic
simulators that you'll find so just like
a real couple
[Music]
music Adam identified for quite a long
time now and I'm such a huge fan since
I've started recording him certainly it
has made everything so much easier to
add it but today we're checking out the
Animal Center 5 it's connected to of the
nikon g6 and one of the things that I'm
most excited about this is you can now
shoot in ProRes raw so if you do have
this camera you do have to send it in to
get a firmware update to be able to
shoot in ProRes raw it's our really
great demo of some of the footage that
was shot on here and it looks incredible
[Music]
when I said before that Amazon Alexa was
integrated into over a hundred and
thousand devices did you ever think that
it would be integrated in a gas station
very shortly at Exxon Mobil stations
you'll be able to say Alexa pay for gas
you'll then tell Alexa which pump you're
at the pump will activate you pump your
gas get back in your car drive away and
it is automatically charged securely to
your Amazon pay you can activate it
using any Alexa devices so you do have
the Alexa app on your phone you could
just use that but if you have to here
but it's anything it's Alexa enabled
that is connected to your Amazon account
do we able to drive away and pay I need
this now now if all of the gas prices
weren't so ridiculously expensive I'm
waiting for the Amazon electric car
where's that Alexa left side
[Music]